les messieurs bonjour et bienvenue à
cette émission spéciale de tam qui vous
parvient direct du palais des congrès de
montréal pourquoi as tu des congrès mais
parce que ici c'est tient la 8e édition
du salon de l'immigration et
d'intégration au québec alors un salon
qui a pour thématique l'emploi et
surtout la régionalisation de
l'immigration alors autour de moi
plusieurs personnes très intéressantes
vous aurez du plaisir à les entendre
nathalie rochefort qui une femme
politique mais aussi et surtout
maintenant présidente et fondatrice de
coop cofondatrice de loisirs de de gamme
en voilà qui est un organisme qui aide
les nouveaux arrivants les immigrantes
à ses côtés on à nathalie et sain qui
elle est une grande des cas une
expérience très intéressante à nous
raconter benoît nom d'eric qui lui est
représentant de la chambre
la fédération dis-je des chambres de
commerce du québec les directeurs des
programmes d'immigration dont jours et
puis on à madame madame faut que je
retrouve madame line
voilà voilà madame line lagacé voilà
désolé line lagacé qui est
vice-présidente croissance des
entreprises et investissements étrangers
chez québec international et à tout
seigneur tout honneur monsieur jonathan
shaw daiki un peu le responsable de tout
ce qui est ici parce que c'est le
cofondateur du salon il est surtout le
président du conseil d'administration
d'immigrants québec inc un québec qui
est l'organisateur de ce grand événement
bonjour bonjour voilà d'abord jonathan
comment est venue l'idée de créer ce
salon bon l'idée l'idée existe depuis
bien longtemps il fallait la réaliser en
fait c'était surtout de mettre sous un
même toit tous les acteurs du milieu et
de s'assurer finalement pour les
nouveaux arrivants qu'ils aient la
chance de pouvoir rencontrer rapidement
les ressources d'aller à la rencontre
finalement des programmes qui sont
destinés finalement à leur intégration
tout ça dans les meilleures conditions
évidemment gratuitement voilà et donc in
england québec qui n'aime pas les riches
qui a un qui est l'organisateur québec
est un organisme sans but lucratif qui
existe depuis maintenant 12 ans qui est
un organisme qui a comme vocation
finalement d'être le premier média
d'information sur l'immigration au
québec pour encore une fois que les
personnes soient bien informés pour
réussir et immigrants québec a eu la
chance de croiser le chemin d'un
monsieur qui s'appelle christophe
berthet qui est notre directeur général
aujourd'hui christophe est arrivé un
jour avec un de ses collègues et il
avait le projet d'un salon donc on a
mélangé finalement nos efforts migrants
québec depuis maintenant huit éditions
gère tous les ans au palais des congrès
de montréal cet événement rassembleur
nathalie rochefort il ya plusieurs
organismes qui travaillent qui viennent
en aide aux immigrés aux nouveaux
arrivants alors en quoi est-ce que de
gama se démarque des six organismes
dégâts n'ont fait aucune discrimination
basée sur le statut donc les millions
soit visiteurs en ayant tout à l'heure
qui est soudeur qui veut savoir
commencer à en venir au québec mais pas
de souci on vole on veut l'aider on va
l'accompagner
kl immigrants soient là depuis 20 ans 30
ans disent pas comment je fais pour
collecter des fonds de pension que j'ai
sur l'argent que j'ai gagné dans
d'autres pays
ben on va s'occuper aussi m'ont même dit
qu'on va s'occuper aussi du jeune
dévêtissent ou du risque dans permanent
en fait on se veut une plateforme qui va
rediriger vers des organismes vont
prendre à coeur et qui vont mettre au
sein de leur organisation l'humain parce
que l'immigrant ce n'est pas qu'un
travailleur c'est d'abord et avant tout
un humain c'est un humain qu'à des
besoins sociaux qui a des besoins
familiaux et personnels
comment s'habiller pour survivre à
l'hiver c'est tout bête mais c'est quoi
être parent au québec ce pas la même
chose qu'en afrique ou en europe
donc c'est vraiment la question du
quotidien évidemment on parle d'emploi
parce que sans emploi
c'est quand même difficile mais je donne
souvent comme exemple un jeune qui est
arrivé ici dans une situation
personnelle très compliqué au delà de
son statut personnel ce qu'ils avaient
besoin c'était de sentir accepté d'avoir
un réseau bien avant d'avoir un travail
parce que c'est un jeune qui était déjà
en état de grande détresse
et justement donc avec tout ce que vous
avez à offrir ça nécessite beaucoup de
ressources aussi de votre part pour
pouvoir couvrir les multiples besoins
qui peuvent vous être
on va dire demander en fait nous notre
grande parce qu'on n'est pas financée
par l'état québécois parce que justement
on fait aucune discrimination fait pas
de segmentation donc on on est basée sur
les ressources bénévoles donc on a un
gros réseau on n'hésite pas à faire
appel à des jambes et j'ai telle
situation qu'est ce qu'on pense qu est
ce que tu peux faire qui tue conique
pourrait aider et on réfère pas
seulement pour dire achetant vos
ouailles m6 est par exemple je te
raconte seconde royaume siéger telle
personne que je connais appelle là on va
faire un suivi avec cette personne là
c'est vraiment une relation qui est
basée sur l'humain d'abord et avant tout
de la alors nathalie ezer vous vous êtes
une immigrante d'abord avant avoir
choisi de venir au canada plutôt
qu'ailleurs
la chance qu'on a eu 6 et le canada le
québec qui nous a choisis on a une offre
d'emploi pour mon conjoint et on est
atterré directement à sainte adèle dans
les laurentides en on est bien heureux
et là dessus on a vraiment été content
parce que les valeurs de là
de la culture québécoise la façon dont
les gens sont et communiquent entre eux
nous correspondait complètement et on a
construit notre vie ici maintenant et
donc toujours heureuses de votre choix
on est très heureux très heureux par le
positivisme qu'on trouve ici
la majorité des français à montréal
vivent au plateau mont royal
vous vous êtes donc les laurentides est
ce que ça ne vous manque pas cette
communauté et puis voilà toutes les
boulangeries et toutes les belles choses
du bloc au mont royal pour deux raisons
déjà ça me manque pas parce que le fait
de venir dans un pays étranger c'était
vraiment pour connaître et communier
avec la culture locale
donc ça avait aucun intérêt pour moi de
rester entre français et ensuite on
trouve la sainte adèle des très bonnes
boulangeries avec notamment des français
qui sont à la tête des pâtisseries donc
il ya aucun problème de ce côté là voilà
prévient alors bon de nos madrid
vous êtes directeur des communications
pour le programme d'immigration dise que
la fédération des chambres de commerce à
votre fédération a lancé un programme
qui sur le papier a l'air très
intéressant qui est-ce qui s'intitule un
emploi en sol québécois est le quoi
s'agit-il donc le programme un emploi
seule québécoise un processus novateur
parce qu'au québec avait beaucoup
d'initiatives de régionalisation de
l'immigration mais des faussetés isolé
spontanée donc nous on a la chance à la
fédération des chambres de commerce du
québec d'avoir une structure de chambre
de commerce établi dans toutes les
régions du québec
donc on parle la structure des chambres
de commerce on
recrute des employeurs actuellement on
est déjà à près de 900 employeurs pour
3000 emplois disponibles donc d'une mois
de novembre les employeurs on leur fait
de la sensibilisation aux pauvres qu'ils
soient intéressés à embaucher des
personnes immigrantes parce que dans
notre programme c'est les personnes
immigrantes qui rencontrent les
personnes des employeurs les décideurs
donc on parle des personnes immigrantes
de montréal avec les organismes de
régionalisation qui font
l'accompagnement nous ont ce qu'on fait
c'est qu'on recrute les employeurs on
regarde les sites rêver des individus
est on prêt qu'elle fuit les individus
pour des entrevues avec les employeurs
ont fait un voyage d'une journée aller
retour un séjour exploratoire en région
par exemple
ce vendredi on va
saguenay-lac-saint-jean en avion on va
charlevoix un avion un groupe d'une
trentaine de personnes vont rencontrer
une vingtaine d'employeurs ils sont
préqualifiés pour les emplois qui sont
disponibles et ensuite on fait une
découverte du milieu de vie pour
s'assurer que la personne qui a un
emploi ou qu'ils ont une offre d'emploi
plus adhérer à la communauté
est-ce que ça produit des résultats
probants après une journée
est ce qu'on réussit à par exemple on
est allé il ya deux semaines à montmagny
et on a déjà quatre personnes qui ont
déménagé à montmagny qui travaillent à
montmagny on est allé à val-d'or à
l'automne deux personnes qui ont
déménagé à chapais des
électromécaniciens il ya un ingénieur
électrique à val d'or lui a décidé de
déménager il ya trouvé un emploi et sa
femme avait besoin d'un emploi et la
communauté de val d'or avec la chambre
de commerce retrouver un emploi
d'architecte à sa fin actuellement
à peu près un an on a une cinquantaine
de familles qui ont fait le choix de
différentes régions
madame lagacé vous par contre c'est plus
les l'international qui vous intéressent
le bit présidente croissance des
entreprises investissements étrangers
chez québec international
bon d'abord pour nos auditeurs ou
téléspectateurs
un petit rappel ckoi québec
international effectivement donc québec
est annoncé l' agence de développement
économique de la grande région de la
ville de québec
et pourquoi un agent de développement
économique s'intéresse tellement à
l'attraction talent dans sa région
c'est que effectivement la disponibilité
de main d'oeuvre était devenu et le je
parle depuis dix ans maintenant et été
et est encore l'enjeu principal pour la
croissance des entreprises c'est un
frein majeur pour rappeler que la région
québec avec un taux de chômage
actuellement de 3 points 8 % ya
actuellement vingt mille postes dans le
dernier trimestre sont disponibles c'est
une des seules régions au canada
quelconque eu une croissance économique
continue depuis les 22 dernières années
donc on est dans une situation de plein
emploi depuis plus de dix ans et les
besoins étaient énormes donc on a dû se
pencher faut comprendre aussi que la
région québec comme à peu près toutes
les régions du québec
on est en déficit d'attraction parce que
la région actuellement on attire en
environ six points 2 % d'immigrants dans
notre population
mais le poids économique des cas - poids
démographique est quand même de près de
10%
donc même au niveau de la traction on
est déficitaire par rapport à
l'immigration
donc on devait être en mesure de mieux
se positionner sur les marchés
j marché mais les parcelles
internationaux demandeur pour permettre
justement
positionné les opportunités de québec et
de faire justement venir on travaille
quand même de proximité parce que pour
nous faut pas négliger les immigrants
qui sont déjà sur le territoire sur
lequel balises migrants s'installent à
mauriac je pense pourrait avoir voir les
opportunités que la région québec d'un
très bon meneur d'hommes c'est avec
nicolas bazin comme la fédération des
chambres de commerce qu'on travaille
aussi sur la régionalisation de
l'immigration mais d'immigration des
gens juste moi jle qu'échoira tout le
panel bon il ya des immigrants très
nombreux ici beaucoup plus ex la
recherche d'emploi est bon là on a des
missions à l'étranger pour chercher pour
recruter des gens vont venir ici
est ce qu'on ne peut pas déjà s'occuper
de ceux qui sont sur place voir dans
quelle mesure est ce qu'ils peuvent être
utiles
buté est évident qu'un enjeu majeur
lorsque les immigrants sont des gens
installés par exemple à montréal c'est
que pour les migrants qui réussit
justement ce faire un premier en
s'installant montréal le déraciner d'un
enjeu quand même majeurs puis tout les
chiffres sont là à québec actuellement
le taux d'activité chez des immigrants
est supérieure à la population moyenne
le taux d'activité le premier au canada
il ya 67 parce que 68% des immigrés qui
sont au travail le taux de chômage est
quand même 2 7% sur la peau peur dans la
population immigrante
c'est quand même très bas par rapport à
l'enfant du taux de chômage à y avait
entre autres à montréal
donc il ya plein d'opportunités mais on
a quand même de la difficulté à attirer
donc il faudrait je pense que le facteur
principal ce que les gens qui sont déjà
installés à montréal qui ont déjà réussi
à s'établir un premier réseau c'est
extrêmement difficile pour eux de se
dire est ce une deuxième fois malgré le
fait qu'on offre des opportunités
intéressant nathalie rochefort
je dirais que c'est d'abord et avant
tout une relation humaine
actuellement je suis déménagé d'été
passe dans un petit village de 2000 147
habitants
je suis déjà réussi à attirer un médecin
que l'avenir s'établit à bientôt
j'ai un couple belge qui est à aussi sur
montréal sont minces en italie mais en
pratique quand on leur parle de
pierreville nous avons le village quand
même
on leur dit n'est pas un dos monsieur le
maire vous accueillir on vous présentait
le restaurateur on représente du monde
et les sens que celle issue mais qui
accueille d'autres humains et on leur
dit peu importe nos différences l'autre
façon un papa qui a qui rend ton enfant
à l'école pour la première fois je n'ai
pas pour nous en parler toi papa qui
stresse et c'est peu importe le pays
d'origine
ce peu importe la région donc le
problème de régionalisation sic souvent
c'est des trucs très informel l'année
passée de jeux secs de gamme sans
ressources on avait une employée on a
placé 60 personnes pourquoi est ce qu'on
attend des résultats comme ça juste un
mentos des relations personnelles versus
des fonctionnaires que j'ai moi le terme
j'en ai pas d'eau qui sont dans des
organisations qui n'étaient pas des
relations directes
c'est quand on préfère quelqu'un québec
on va référer à soit vous vous référez à
un humain on va on passera pas
nécessairement par tout processus de
régionalisation
je m'attends pas répond un peu plus
précisément à votre question finalement
je pense qu'il n'y a pas une façon de
répondre au problème
on a un problème démographique majeur au
québec faut pas se le cacher je pense
qu'on en est tous conscients donc c'est
pas seulement une pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre aujourd'hui c'est une
pénurie de citoyens et de québécois dans
les prochaines années à laquelle on est
confronté et c'est vrai pour toutes les
régions et c'est aussi vrai pour
montréal donc je pense qu'il faut pas de
lui ménager nos efforts je pense que nos
amis de québec international s'en vont à
l'étranger pour aller nous attirer du
beau monde
je pense que les gens qui sont ici sont
tous conscients de cette réalité et on
travaille tous ensemble j'allais dire on
sait déjà croisé à paris pour les
journées québec il ya des missions qui
sont donnés un peu partout à travers le
monde québec international et dans 7
pays je pense cette année en tout cas
c'est ça donne le vertige
ça donne le vertige sincèrement mais
c'est une problématique qui est un enjeu
majeur parce que on parlait de bassins
tout à l'heure dans le monde entier le
monde dans les pays développés on
cherche des talents on cherche des
compétences des gens qui sont capables
de venir remplir aujourd'hui nos besoins
évidemment de travail mais comme le
disait nathalie des besoins humains et
dans un tel un tel contexte je veux dire
on lutte contre d'autres pays contre
d'autres villes donc il faut que tous
ensemble on se tiennent serena au québec
pour réussir à aller plus loin c'est la
force d'un événement comme celui-ci qui
est unique au monde
c'est vraiment quelque chose de
particulier moi je pourrais vous
présentez des pays dans lesquels on a
des salon de l'expatriation
on incite les jeunes à partir nous ici
on leur dit venez vous accueille donc
c'est quand même merveilleux comme
message qu'on leur donne quand il ya des
intervenants aussi sérieux avec des
équipes aussi poussé avec des programmes
comme comme un emploi en sol québécois
où effectivement on leur dit bien
regarder non seulement vous veut mais en
plus on va vous prendre par la main et
on va vous accompagner jusqu'à votre job
jusqu'à votre vie jusqu'à votre école
les quantifier ce genre de choses là
mais huit ans plus tard ce que vous
percevez quand même déjà des résultats
concrets de cette manifestation
je dirais que à chaque jour quasiment on
en voit mais c'est sûr qu'il ya une
prise de conscience de la société alors
c'est pas seulement inhérents migrants
québec je pense qu'on travaille tous
ensemble à ça mais c'est un vrai enjeu
aujourd'hui qui est enfin mis de l'avant
comme il se doit c'est-à-dire un enjeu
de société qui danse on doit débattre
tous ensemble et surtout qui appelle à
des réponses concrètes
aujourd'hui la reprise d'entreprises au
québec c'est un enjeu la création
d'emplois je veux dire elle est forte
mais si on donne pas des employés aux
entreprises la réalité dont on parle pas
beaucoup c'est des carnets de commandes
qui sont remplies et qu'on peut pas
honorer
donc on doit continuer d'accompagner
cette croissance est pas seulement une
question d'argent c'est une question de
société de dire à un moment donné on a
envie d'être la société
finalement qui remplit son potentiel
quand on choisit des immigrants sur
dossier parce qu'ils ont des compétences
on se doit nous en tant que société de
leur donner la chance de les exprimer
donc c'est ce qu'on fait tous ensemble
et puis on a beaucoup de chance je
dirais d'avoir un écosystème qui
répondent aussi bien après toutes ces
années et qui grandit encore
nathalie valleix voulu ajouter c'est que
effectivement si on a un premier cercle
de réseaux qui se créent quand on arrive
dans un endroit nous a exclus pas non
plus d'aller dans un autre endroit pour
aller chercher d'autres caractéristiques
de vie qu'on trouve pas dans le premier
puis les régions sont quand même c'est
vrai que le québec est très grand mais
la plupart des régions qui sont très
forte économiquement sont quand même
très proche de montréal ce qui fait que
c'est selon moi possible de se déplacer
d'aller chercher d'autres choses est de
recréer un cercle en réseau d'autant que
les gens sont très accueillants région
il ya pas l'anonymat de la grande ville
comme montréal et je pense que c'est
encore plus accueillants et beaucoup
plus chaleureux oui oui benoît notre
côté lorsqu'on a développé le programme
un emploi québécois ce qu'on a constaté
ces 85 % des personnes immigrantes qui
arrivent au québec
arrivé à montréal et reste à montréal
alors que 55 % des emplois sont à
l'extérieur de montréal
donc en termes de dispersion du bassin
de main-d'oeuvre disponible il ya un
enjeu parce qu'à montréal le taux de
chômage est presque le double pour les
nouveaux arrivants que les natifs
donc c'est vraiment partir de l'ofppt
des fois les personnes immigrantes quand
on les rencontre
ils nous disent les régions parce que le
mot région pour nous fait un sens mais
pour quelqu'un qui vient de notre pays
fait un autre sens permanent à ce que
d'électricité est ce que l'eau courante
à ce que dit wife et en régions
le cac qui vont avoir le vent d'autan
qui vont à val d'or qu'ils vont à
saguenay laisseront que c'est une ville
à échelle humaine où ils ont tout les
services mais on peut plus des espaces
moins qu'on ne rangent - trafic de la
bonne heure puis peuvent s'installer dès
fois le coût de la maison y est beaucoup
plus intéressant donc région ne veut pas
y arriver à éviter mais c'est ça la
beauté qui se connaissent aussi
ils s'entraident moi c'était mon premier
hiver en région cet hiver heureusement
que j'avais des bons voisins parce que
c'est le pays de villa faisait ouais ok
c'est pas cool ça mais le voisinage y
pour beaucoup aussi l'entr'aide je me
suis plus de quel pays mais il le
village qui élève l'enfant
c'est ce qu'on retrouve dans les
villages québec dans les régions du
québec ce qu'on voit peut-être pas à
montréal
voilà c'est ce que vous avez des régions
cibles quand vous allez faire des
prospections l'étranger c'est sûr que
pour nous le fait français quand même un
élément important donc la première cible
sur lequel on peut être sa voiture des
régions un francophone également
francophile parce que actuellement on
est quand même beaucoup en amérique
latine sur lesquels depuis huit ans on a
réussi à bien un mouvement de masse je
vais donner l'exemple du brésil par
exemple actuellement si on pose la
question aux gens aux jeunes du brésil à
savoir s'ils connaissent une ville au
québec
ça va être la ville de québec à
montmagny la métropole et ça c'est parce
que ça fait huit ans qu'on est là et on
s'aperçoit que les gens on a enclenché
un processus de francisation avec eux
ils leur apprennent le français c'est
des gens avec qui on continue est en
communication et peut-être que c'est pas
notre champion la planète qu'on veut le
voir la première fois mais c'est vrai
notre champion l'année d'après donc on
en fait en sorte de justement d'amener
ce rouage là donc pour répondre à votre
question actuellement les pays cibles
sur lesquels nous sommes davantage sont
bien sûr la france et la belgique
on dirait que ça va de soi d'aller dans
ce territoire là mais de l'afrique du
nord donc
niveau du maroc la tunisie de plus en
plus l'algérie et en amérique latine
trois pays qui sont nos pays c'est à
dire la colombie le mexique et le brésil
qui est vraiment au niveau technologique
entre nous un pays fort actuellement au
niveau des technologies en général je ne
pense qu'à metz at il très privé ces
salons ils meurent à québec
mais est-ce que vous recevez vous avez
un coup de pouce quand même des
autorités parce qu'au fond c'est tout le
monde qui gagnent la façon dont on a
voulu procéder dès le départ c'était de
surtout pas elle est grugé la part du
gâteau qui revient aux organismes de
terrain parce que la réalité objectif
c'est qu'au quotidien ce sont ces
organismes seller de gamal est promis et
tellement d'autres qui sont sur le
terrain qui font un travail
nous on n'accueille pas les immigrants
dans nos bureaux donc on estimé qu'il
n'était pas normal
j'avais dire qu'on a grugé dans cet
argent là de fait on a plutôt été du
côté du privé ce qui nous paraissait
complètement logique puisque finalement
ben on dit souvent à qui profite le
crime
aujourd'hui le privé a des moyens et à
des besoins donc ça nous paraissait
normal et en fait ça a très bien
fonctionné
justement parce qu'on a travaillé de
cette façon là donc on ne demande pas à
proprement parler de subventions par
contre évidemment ben comme toute
initiative qui est intéressante
on a des kiosques qui représente le
gouvernement est également évidemment
toutes sortes d'organisations publiques
et parapubliques
donc on a la chance aujourd'hui je pense
d'avoir tous les acteurs du milieu tout
simplement et on les a parce que
justement à aucun moment on a essayé de
prendre leur place donc c'est un travail
d'équipé encore une fois ça fonctionne
tenté aussi longtemps qu'ils en a pas un
qui essaient de gruger l'autre
après ultime manche je pense que le
besoin il est pas seulement au niveau
des finances même si ça coûte cher de
louer un palais des congrès comme celui
là c'est bien évidemment d'être en
mesure de fournir à l'année longue
une continuité de service et c'est là où
nous on compte énormément sur nos
partenaires qui eux l'ont bien compris
et qui développe je dirai tout une offre
capable de répondre aux besoins des uns
et des autres donc cesser il n'y a pas
de yagma pas de mailles du filet qui
soit trop petit les gens ils vont se
retrouver dans un événement organisé par
de gama ils vont s'en aller faire une
journée de repérage avec benoît ils vont
se retrouver dans les laurentides et
puis de fait ils vont partir voir québec
c'est essentiel pour nous que l'on soit
là où on en a le besoin et notre
industrie essaye de s'organiser parce
que évidemment il ya des enjeux et des
besoins pour justement qu'on tombe pas
dans le dans le drame du passionnel
souvent quand on parle d'immigration ce
que ce qu'on voit dans les réseaux
sociaux les discussions tout ça c'est
pas les immigrés qui sont ceux ci sont
ceux-là les immigrants ils ont pour la
plupart pas demander grand chose si ce
n'est qu'on leur laisse une chance
d'exprimer ce pour quoi ils ont été
choisis donc nous on parle de chiffres
on parle de choses qui sont des données
très précises et très concrètes c'est
pour ça qu'on s'associe avec des
montréal international québec
international chambre de commerce parce
que ce sont des interlocuteurs crédibles
qui sont sur le terrain qui comprennent
les enjeux du québec
on n'est pas en train dira ouvrait la
porte fait ceci fait cela on n'est pas
des donneurs de leçon on est tous
ensemble en train d'essayer de rendre
concrète une réalité et de d'améliorer
gérer la condition de notre société
une question générale qui s'adresse à
tout le monde ici bon souvent pour les
nouveaux arrivants et un problème abus
problèmes généraux c'est la
reconnaissance des diplômes tout ce qui
est un nombre et aussi le fait de
l'absence d'expérience canadienne
d'histoire des obstacles qui font très
bon certaines personnes qui voudraient
est utile ne pouvait être utile se
retrouve ses récits clan des petits
boulots qui ne sont pas nécessairement
des bouleaux valorisant pour eux est-ce
que vous avez des idées là-dessus à bali
oui je suis parti à mon compte en tant
que travailleur autonome donc c'est vrai
que j'avais la chance de pas avoir
besoin de faire reconnaître mes diplômes
parce que je suis pas médecin je suis
dans l'expérience client donc cédé des
diplômes sont reconnus ici mais j'avais
la même question ne pas avoir
d'expérience au canada et ce qui a été
déjà on peut valoriser l'expérience
qu'on a eu en france parce que les gens
sont tout à fait compréhensif et ils
sont à l'écouté mais également j'ai fait
énormément de bénévolat donc ça m'a créé
une expérience assez facilement
puis après des petits contrats puis des
contrats plus gros qui progressivement
j'ai fait ma place
la porte du bénévolat c'est 5 fruits de
noix la fameuse première expérience
québécois enfin il ya une des choses
qu'il faut comprendre au québec c'est
que notre marché du travail est basé sur
l'expérience alors qu'à l'international
seul marché du travail souvent basés sur
la connaissance
la différence c'est qu'une personne qui
finit l'université ici un québécois va
aussi chercher sa première expérience du
marché du travail parce que les
entreprises veulent s'assurer que les
gens qui sont en poste de décision dépôt
stratégique connaissent les opérations
donc c'est de prendre des postes
d'entrée pour lesquels des fois on est
un peu sur qualifier on mais avoir une
discussion avec l'employeur pour savoir
s'il ya des possibilités d'avancement
lui faire parler
sa culture organisationnelle je te
prends un exemple participants l'année
dernière thierry le gall et un
participant de nos activités à
drummondville
desjardins a décidé de l'embaucher lui
voulait être pas indicateurs financiers
mais il y avait un poste de caissier qui
est ouvert lui c'est dit j'ai accepté
parce de quessy mais à ce que vous
pouvez me faire progresser dans votre
organisation
après six mois il a obtenu une promotion
pour être planificateur financier
emplois qu'ils occupent présentement
donc c'est possible il suffit d'avoir
les bonnes stratégies puis de comprendre
la réalité du marché du travail une
atonie pays comme en europe notamment
on a beaucoup plus de facilité ici à
s'intégrer parce qu'on a justement le
savoir être et on laisse les gens
s'exprimer pour qui ils sont et on les
juge pas justement tant que ça sur leur
diplôme donc c'est beaucoup plus facile
de trouver un emploi ici que de le
trouver en europe par exemple ou une
nathalie ensuite juste pour venir
reconnaissance des diplômes à ce que je
suggère à ceux qui ont des difficultés
faites pas faire votre connaissance
initiale par le midi surtout pas par le
midi le ministère des migrations
diversité inclusion allaient plutôt dans
une école qui correspond ce que vous
avez faire par exemple vous êtes
ingénieur à les achats polytechnique
aller ats
ali de faire ta l'équivalence et ensuite
vous l'envoyer au miti va avoir la
validation officielle donc eu lyon la
connaissance fine de votre profession de
votre métier et dès ce moment là le
fonctionnel pour faire la quitte à lunel
l'analyse officielle va être beaucoup
plus à même de bien comprendre que vous
faites parce que c'est pas tout le monde
qui comprend tous les métiers c'est
possible dans notre eau il ya des
métiers qui existent plus ou moins ici
mais qui existe dans d'autres pays
donc peut être aussi conscient de ça et
je reviens aussi sur première expérience
le bénévolat oui mais encore là peu
importe d'expérience tels que j'ai des
exemples plus finir on me demande une
première expérience québécoise
ok vas travailler en usine travaillé
comme manutentionnaire sanit une
expérience québécoise
donc je vois pas d'employeur ah ouais
mais tu as pas d'expérience non j'en ai
moi pour faire différentes actions à
l'international
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya deux éléments
l'attend ce qu'on voit beaucoup celles
employant qui n'est pas nécessairement
besoin de la reconnaissance du splendid
le besoin de son côté c'est beaucoup
plus de savoir est-ce que ce que tu as
appris comme compétence correspond aux
besoins de compétences que j'ai et nous
on a mis en place vraiment des tests
techniques à l'international pour
permettre même avant les entrevues et
même après une entrevue dans certains
cas est en mesure de mesurer cet élément
là parce que la majorité des employeurs
quelquefois la reconnaissance du diplôme
est beaucoup plus pour l'individu devant
nous qui lui si jamais pas ce premier
emploi qui l'obtient devrait ce point se
reclasser aie aie aie
pour lui c'est peut-être important de
pouvoir avoir un document qui certifie
que et son niveau de compétence ou
diplôme correspond à quelque chose au
niveau québécois
mais lorsqu'on est un recrutement le
besoin n'est pas nécessairement lors il
est beaucoup plus dans une
reconnaissance de la compétence de
l'individu qu'est ce qu'il est en mesure
de faire donc les tests techniques
souvent répondre à ça et pour l'autre
dimension l'eau dimension c'est vraiment
des employeurs qui ont besoin de cette
équivalence de diplôme l'eau pour par
exemple je donnais l'exam au niveau du
service conseil en informatique dans la
région québec comme le principal client
est souvent le gouvernement du québec
mais là ils ont besoin de certifier
qu'ils sont d'un niveau par exemple
baccalauréat ou techniques et l'offre
d'emploi et sub en conditionnelle à
l'obtention de l'équivalence du diplôme
et ça devient un enjeu important et sa
place souvent les entreprises de québec
dans une concurrence un peu un peu
déloyale parce que la même firme
informatique à montréal que son client
se reprendre en plus privé n'aura pas
besoin de cette équivalence de diplôme
là celui québec risquent d'avoir besoin
de ça crée un peu
si d'un côté j'ai une offre
conditionnelle à l'équivalence du plan
mais de l'autre côté j'en ai pas besoin
pour avoir accepté une offre à montréal
mais c'est sûr que ça devienne
intéressant pour l'institut d'accepter
une oeuvre sur montréal par exemple il
ya des éléments comme ça moi je pense
qu'il faut pas négliger pour en dessous
de plus en plus fluide pour
effectivement j'ai encore beaucoup de
difficultés que la refondation du
diplôme dans les cégeps tout seul ça
devient comme une concurrence il se
chicanent un peu de savoir qui vaut
faire cette équivalence look en principe
on devrait avoir une chez pas mal de
développer cette expertise
dans tel domaine mais je m'adresser à
toi que tu sois montréal croyant mais
l'on comprend ce que chacun développe un
peu son expertise qui se concurrencent
ceux qui vaut faire cette
reconnaissance-là passant leur donne
également de diplomation il somme je
trouve ça extrêmement de match n'est pas
due to perform et on devrait faut
travailler très fort pour assurer la
fluidité justement de cette
reconnaissance et surtout la rapidité de
la reconnaissance des dissidents et
diplômes techniquement c'est le midi qui
se pose est le père d'un vraie vie bon
on repassera la qualification québec qui
est rendu à un guichet unique était
quelques cassures montréal avant peut
être une porte d'entrée pour les
personnes immigrantes pour avoir cette
reconnaissance des acquis et des
compétences
donc il ya des mesures qui se passe son
temps remplace qui se développe
je pense que ce qui est important c'est
surtout sur le terrain on travaille en
complémentarité plutôt qu'en compétition
parce que des fois malheureusement il ya
des situations qui amène les
organisations à travailler en
compétition alors on devrait tous être
pour le bien de l'individu que choisi le
québec pour faciliter son intégration
lui tendre la main pour faciliter son
parcours ici que ce soit à montréal ou
que ça soit en région
il vous entend ouais je voudrais que la
problématique est plus vaste encore
parce que
au demeurant tout ce qui a été dit est
très vrai et encore une fois on doit
tous travailler en collaboration
il ya des programmes qui existent il ya
des services qui sont déjà à porter pour
ça les programmes d'incitation à
l'employabilité pour que les employeurs
finalement récupère une partie du
salaire donc ça minimise le risque pour
eux il ya également des programmes un
petit peu innovant qui sont montés dans
certaines régions parce que justement
les besoins sont criants et un moment
donné on a besoin d'eux d'informer et
d'accompagner finalement les employeurs
dans leur démarche
parce que ce sont parfois des démarches
administratives qui sont lourdes donc
pour un employeur lambda c'est pas
nécessairement quelque chose de facile
ou d'habituel et puis au delà de ça même
si on les forme faut aussi les informer
parce que ben s'ils n'ont pas l'habitude
d'avoir des immigrants ou des gens qui
sont issues d'autres communautés
ben ça peut être un frein donc notamment
dans les régions du québec où on est
moins habitué à voir des migrants en
tout cas pendant longtemps ça a été le
cas aujourd'hui on a un travail à faire
et donc collectivement là encore on voit
des ressources qui se crée un des
programmes d d d d idée finalement pour
essayer d'améliorer cette réalité de
sorte que effectivement la
reconnaissance du diplôme des
compétences des acquis mais surtout de
ce que l'individu à apporter à la
société puisse donner cours finalement
eu lieu à une amélioration j'irai du
ratio dont on parlait tout à l'heure des
55 % des emplois qui sont en région et
qui ont besoin d'être pourvus attirer
les ennemis d'un soc une question des
réputations bon
nathalie sézanne a dit tout à l'heure
que donc en france il y avait quand même
cet intérêt pour le canada pour le
québec madame sillonné le monde pour
recruter des gens est ce que les
événements locaux exemple l'algérie
québec ou encore le débat sur les le
poids des synergies est ce que c'est des
choses qui peuvent nuire à votre travail
à l'étranger où cela n'a pas d'effet du
tout quand l'événement de la mosquée
québec est arrivé on a vraiment fait une
attention particulière à savoir est ce
qu'il ya un impact parce que en même
temps nous avions une mission virtuel et
entrons en afrique du nord
donc on voulait voir est ce qu'il y
avait effectivement un impact négatif
par rapport à tout ça on a vu que si
vous souvenez la tempête la mosquée une
première phase c'est à dire qu'on
croyait que c'était vraiment un attentat
de quelqu'un enfin quand de l'islande
qui attaquaient des québécois et là on
voyait que ça circule et beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup dans les journaux et
tout ça et on se demandait si
effectivement il y aurait eu un impact
qui par la suite on s'est aperçu que
c'est un québécois c'était l'inversé
réalité comme situation
et c'est drôle parce que ça le chute est
réellement au niveau de l'information
internationale ceci étant dit
l'un pas qualité mieux dans ce que c'est
le contraire mais ils m'ont offert une
attention particulière pour appeler
directement des individus est ce que
vous avez des crânes de ce que vous avez
et la réponse était vraiment une
connaissance et un acte isolé sur lequel
sont attachées vraiment pas du tout du
tout la réputation dont est bon c'est un
acte effectivement certains acquis
solides sur lequel la chute médiatique à
tomber quand même très rapidement au
niveau international si ç'avait été une
situation qui avait été répétitives je
pense que les bateaux réitère ce moment
là beaucoup plus grand mais pour
l'instant ce que je peux vous garantir
c'est que on a eu un effet 0 juste pour
votre information la dernière mission en
un conte de fées au niveau de l'afrique
du nord par exemple on a eu c'était 22 8
mai le cv que nous avons reçues pour
cette employant qui se déplaçait sur un
site à tunisie cette fois là et donc
c'est énorme
et à chaque fois qu'on se déplace pour
nous aucun impact même mode et quelques
fonds mentionne l'événement et non
celles auxquelles on dirait que les gens
on conscience que la qualité de vie la
sécurité tous ces éléments là sont
présents et satan sorte que la volonté
justement l'intérêt du tout été touchés
par rapport à cet événement le bien
qu'il veut rebondir sur le sujet on
était
sécuritaire mais je suis j'ai commandé
la vision que j'avais du canada et que
c'était un pays pacifiste et sécuritaire
une réputation à l'international qui ne
se dément pas et c'est vrai aussi bien
pour des que des facteurs effectivement
qui sont négatifs ailleurs donc le
chômage la difficulté à franchir
certains certain plafond de verre
l'ouverture également les communautés
les lgbt les choses comme ça dans
beaucoup de pays c'est difficile pour
eux ils savent qu'ici ce sera plus
facile
évidemment on n'est pas une société
parfaite mais on s'entend que nos
imperfections les assume et qu'on a un
peu tendance à en parler donc c'est sûr
que c'est quand même plus facile moi je
suis pas perdre deux enfants je ne
verrai pas aujourd'hui les faire l'une
dans certains pays parce que je trouve
juste ça moins agréable plus plus
inquiétant donc je pense qu'on a
effectivement une qualité de vie comme
le disait linky qui ne se dément pas et
tous les ans dans les classements le
québec montréal la ville de québec tout
ça on est tous toujours très bien
classés maintenant au delà de ça je
pense qu'il ya une une vision du monde
un petit peu biaisé j'irai de ce qu'on
présente au québec et pendant longtemps
on en a on en a souffert j'allais dire
avec plaisir mais quand même avec une
réputation où les gens visés par les
québécois ils sont gentils sont ouverts
la société va m'accueillir c'est facile
d'avoir un visa et c'est parce qu'ils
ont vu des reportages où on leur
présentait comme si c'était tout cuit
c'est évidemment pas le cas les
démarches administratives peuvent être
compliquées ça peut être long ça peut
être coûteux ça peut être difficile
voire décourageant je parle même pas du
climat parce que là on est carrément
dans un autre monde mais il faut
comprendre évidemment que ces éléments
là sont des éléments dont aujourd'hui
les immigrants par l'information dans
laquelle ils ont accès
ils en ont conscience donc on leur
raconte pas de krach on sait où on s'en
va et on s'en va faire des missions à
l'étranger justement pour qu'il soit le
mieux informé possible avant même de
venir et sur les difficultés de l'accès
au marché de l'emploi la reconnaissance
des diplômes comme on le faisait
précédemment
même la francisation en forme des gens
la langue française avant qu'il vienne
ici donc c'est dire jusqu'à quel point
on est prêt à faire des efforts pour ça
collectivement encore une fois c'est pas
le rôle seulement du gouvernement c'est
à nous tous de se prendre en main là
dessus mais mais on parle d'intégration
et cette intégration
c'est le deuxième volet en parler
d'abord de évidemment de promotion pour
qu'il y ait de l'immigration et ensuite
de l'intégration et c'est vraiment là
qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup d'efforts à
faire aujourd'hui et pour toujours parce
qu'une fois que les gens sont ici ils
rendent bien compte qu'on n'est pas dans
une société raciste difficile et donc il
faut arrêter un peu de toujours montrer
du doigt de désigner celui qui qui se
plaint il faut je pense qu'il faut qu'on
regarde tous ensemble qu'est ce qui
marche il ya beaucoup de choses qui
fonctionnent dans la région on a des
exemples magnifique oui le panier dans
toutes les cultures on a toujours nos
canards tout il ya des imbéciles pertusa
a pas de sexe et la peau de couleur de
la peau de religion donc oui à des
restrictions au québec ce c'est de la
même façon que j'ai des copains qui sont
hors de son récit se passer aux blancs y
vivent c'est normal c'est la nature
humaine on a peur de ce qui est
différent mais deux minutes qu'on
commence à connecter entre personnes là
on vient de régler le problème je vous
donne un exemple rapide
il ya trois ans on n'a pas cité
l'intégration à varennes de deux coupes
africaines qui venait
démarrer une entreprise de rechapage de
pneus passé les dames patronnesses du
village les filles d'isabelle les
chevaliers de colomb ce donc les gens
plus âgés du village qu'ils ont pris en
main donc les messieurs sont arrivés au
village il était attendu les madame
donne qui avaient l'âge d'or mères les
ont pris en main au magasin des
l'immeuble et les serviettes de table et
cetera candidats achetez pas trop de
choses aux femmes vont arriver via un
gros poisson ils vont tout changer et ce
peu importe le pays
je suis quand les parents sont arrivés
avec les enfants ça a été ça aussi il
est attendu par le village donc faut
arrêter de cesser les programmes si
c'est ça non aussi pour transcender pour
s'assurer que les personnes immigrantes
qui souffrait choix du québec
surtout qu'après on veut le recruter à
l'étranger qui ont fait un match avec un
autre humain que ce soit dans
l'entreprise où que ce soit à l'expert
pour qui est vraiment un lien connexion
avec sa communauté
moi je suis tout à fait raisonnable et
puis le djia c'est le diable est dans
les détails l'intégration le côté humain
je voulais juste côté une une anecdote
on a un couple je pense qu'ils
provenaient du sénégal qui arrive du
côté de les laver de lévis en octobre
dernier et les gens cherchaient un
appartement et on leur donnait lui
laissons les accompagne tout ça de façon
très humaine et plus on leur donne une
liste de logements potentiels est à peu
près trois semaines après je revois le
père de famille et je lui demande puis
est-ce que ça a porté fruit comme un
[ __ ] été dit non l'inédit liant ne
bougeait pas appelé parce que et des
coups de deals vincent vient puis
c'était tout non chauffés non éclairée
je me le suis vraiment les détails et le
côté humain la danse on n'est pas en
mesure de bien accompagner pour ce
monsieur il pensait vraiment que son
logement ça va chauffer pendant tout
l'hiver
il se voyait pas célibataire
nous sommes ici c'est des détails
comment la plus humaine à
l'accompagnement et dans l'intégration
et on pensait que c'était dans notre
projet d'établissement de ce type de
détails
absolument
[Rires]
bon il ya quand même cette perception
selon laquelle les régions peinent à
tirer les immigrants cette perception
est ce que ces interceptions qui est
fausse autour de la table pour avoir
parcouru j'ai fait 25 activités dans les
dernières mois dans différentes régions
du québec
et tant qu'on arrive avec un autobus de
personnes immigrantes qui ont un intérêt
à s'intégrer on voit les sourires et il
ya une constance une constance et la
chaleur humaine c'est à quel point les
gens sont accueillants les gens veulent
découvrir les personnes immigrantes
peu importe le pays ils veulent aussi
partager leur culture
donc je dirais des fois y'a peut-être
l'enjeu du transport encore un qui peut
être un enjeu difficile parce que
lorsqu'on est mais on n'a pas
nécessairement le permis de conduire
tout de suite donc une période de
latence ou ce qu'on attendait de permis
de conduire mais autres cet enjeu de
transport là je pense que les régions
ont beaucoup à offrir des fois le coût
des maisons est presque deux fois moins
cher qu'à montréal il ya aussi beaucoup
d espace donc avoir une maison mais
savoir un terrain aussi pour les enfants
les accueillent les personnes
immigrantes moi ce qui me ce qui me
demandent souvent c'est la qualité des
écoles la qualité des soins de santé
le milieu à ce que c'est un milieu
sécuritaire puis est ce qu'ils vont
pouvoir s'intégrer à la communauté à ce
qu'il ya une communauté d'appartenance
et comme que plusieurs bassins de
communauté que je pense justement à
rouyn noranda où on est allé la semaine
dernière rouyn noranda était basique
bâti par des personnes immigrantes
donc il ya déjà des communautés de
personnes migrantes qui sont présentes
on avait un congolais qui est venu faire
une présentation je dis oui au début de
l'hiver j'avais froid aux joues mais
après je me suis habillé j'aime une
tuque
maintenant je fais du sport d'hiver puis
j'aime ça donc quand on va en région on
se rend compte à quel point que c'est
des gens accueillants chaleureux
puis qui ont un intérêt à connaître les
personnels
oui je passe le plus grand défi à partir
du moment où les opportunités sont bien
et que l'individu est en mesure de
découvrir ce que les régions à offrir je
pense que c'est un parti c'est un pari
gagné en on a tout eu un frigo la grande
difficulté et le positionnement des
régions et le fait de pouvoir faire
ballots de valoriser ces opportunités là
auprès que ce soit à l'international où
ce soit plus localement par exemple sur
un passant devant rien et c'est là que
réside réellement si moi je regarde puis
quand même j'ai quand même le deuxième
pôle économique je suis et dans la
région québec le deuxième pôle
économique du québec et je peine d'aller
sur les territoires internationaux a
positionné quand même mon nom parce que
je suis en concurrence je suis comme une
petite région métropolitaine qui essaye
de jouer dans la cour des grands mais
d'essayer positionner salma énormément
d'efforts et c'est là dessus que les
régions ont besoin de soutien d'un thé
de mettre de l'avant justement ces
opportunités loprais parce que à partir
du moment où se lier la humain ce fait
je gagne
on a tout à fait justement nathalie loi
qui doit attirer la personne parce
qu'elle veut un emploi à la hauteur de
ses compétences
mais c'est le milieu qui va pas en sorte
qu'elle va rester
on reparle et chief l'otan ce qu'on vous
dit de la moitié moins cher qu'à
montréal
chez nous à pierreville les maisons
c'est en 125 250 mais l'on parle
d'hypothèques qui vont varier en tissant
plus 1200 pièces par mois et là je parle
d'un 3 jamais couché avec garage parce
que le garage quatre immigrants je pense
que ça peut être utile mais je regarde
mon propre budget personnel du parti qui
est de montréal centre-ville l'année
passée ça va faire un an juillet et mon
budget coût de la vie c'est-à-dire
électricité nourriture resto etc dit
social ont diminué de moitié
pas parce que moins de choses à faire
tout simplement parce que le coût de la
vie est moins chère
beaucoup moins cher je vais chercher
carrément mes légumes chez le producteur
agricole et mes légumes
je les paye deux fois prix à montréal
parce qu'il ya tout système de transport
dont quelques petits avantages comme ça
et ça me range son heure est venue pour
venir à montréal et sa promenade mais
pour moi à québec
résumé pour répondre à votre question
c'est pas très compliqué en fait je
pense qu à la base on le sait ça sera
pas tout seul les gens vont pas aller en
région comme ça on doit travailler
ensemble pour leur faire connaître ce
qu'il ya d'intéressant et effectivement
il ya beaucoup de choses intéressantes
dans la régionalisation
je pense que le québec au complet a
besoin de s'enrichir de cette diversité
la de cette richesse-là de ses talents
là donc tous ensemble on va y arriver
parce qu'on est on est plus forts
ensemble et puis vient la réalité c'est
que tous ces gens là ils sont ici
physiquement présent donc ça montre bien
un message fort aussi que les régions se
réunissent se mettent ensemble
s'associent et
et qu'ensemble on est capable donc comme
je vous le disais ça sera pas tout seul
mais ça se fait quand même
nathalie c'est que même si les personnes
attirées par un poste il ya pas mal
d'immigrants que je connais que c'est à
montréal qui sont intéressés pour aller
vivre en région mais il manque peut-être
de connaissances
ils ont besoin d'être rassurés sur
l'accessibilité et ils savent après
qu'ils ont trouvé l'espace et la qualité
de vie qui leur convient je pense que
c'est vraiment de la communication en
boutique et il est posté de la rétention
aussi bon la vérité ces instances benoît
l'a dit on à compans d'emplois mais si
par exemple le milieu de vie intéressant
on finit par rester
est ce que c'est on est d'accord avec ça
que la rétro niveau de la rétention oui
on va écouter à québec actuellement 94 %
des gens après cinq ans sont toujours
sur le territoire 94 pour ça on essaie
énorme fête à marianne actuellement 6
84% autour de 84 pour cent en termes de
taux de rétention mais moi je pense que
le cas jeudi que le pari est gagné à
partir du moment où à ce que on a tiré
qu'on encadre bien l'intégration
il ya des efforts à 12h02 des paramètres
sur l'intégration puis je sais pas je
pense que c'est toi nathalie qui
mentionnait les conjoints conjointe
nancy toi qui mentionnait ces efforts là
dans la région de québec ait fallu qu'on
les mette également parce que ça passe
par une intégration globale de la
famille et dans la famille tu peux avoir
un projet d'entreprendre peuvent avoir
un projet d'étudier qui peut avoir aussi
un projet de travailler pour l'autre
conjoint et c'est cette approche que le
malade qu'il faut développer parce que
sinon ce ne serait pas une intégration
réussie sur quelqu'un dans la famille
qui n'a pas réussi à trouver son propre
projet dans ce projet familial et c'est
ce qu'on a mis en place et ce qui fait
en sorte que ça réussit et qu'on retient
région ces temps-là il mérite qu'on
investisse en deuil en fait je pense que
c'est un peu le maître mot là c'est
beaucoup d'argent tout ce qu'on fait
mais à l'échelle de ce que ça rapporte
la société
un immigrant qui vient qui s'installe
qui fait des enfants ici qui travaillent
toute sa vie ici c'est des peanuts donc
il faut arrêter de regarder juste à la
dépense pour garder l'investissement que
ça représente alors justement la suite
des choses pour vous ce salon a l'air de
bien fonctionner immigrants au québec ça
va aussi la suite des choses c'est quoi
écoutez comme je le disais tout à
l'heure on est en train d'essayer
d'organiser encore mieux nos affaires
avec nos partenaires puisons nos
partenariats se renforce ils sont plus
en plus présent à l'année longue et pas
seulement pendant deux jours de salon
notamment avec un événement qui va avoir
lieu cet automne en l'avançant primeur
aujourd'hui mais on va faire un sommet
de l'immigration donc pour que les
acteurs puissent se réunir faire
ressortir les meilleures pratiques
évidemment là dessus on a la chance de
compter sur nos partenaires qui sont de
tous les combats avec nous je dirai
encore une fois on cherche tous des
opportunités d'améliorer nos pratiques
de les faire mieux connaître du grand
public mais évidemment des pouvoirs
publics aussi et c'est évidemment pour
nous un travail de longue haleine mais
c'est un travail qu'on a qu'on a décidé
de prendre depuis le début jusqu'à la
fin et et on est très très très chanceux
parce qu'on est très bien accompagné
dans sa démarche et lille lagacé à leur
québec international vous avez des
projets des choses en vue au cours des
prochains mois deux semaines grosse des
façons en intensification actuellement
ne répondent même pas à la demande des
entreprises
juste pour votre information est passée
de six missions par année un document
international à 11 missions cette année
donc et on rajoute à seulement d'autres
d'attraction d'étudiants et de rétention
des étudiants internationaux sur le
territoire donc c'est énormément de
travail donc c'est une intensification
passe du simple au double et ça le
transparu l'année dernière c'est plus de
1200 travailleurs qu'on a attiré chez
nous c'est ce qui fait environ 2500
nouveaux arrivants juste dans une année
donc on en est très fier mais c'est
vraiment l'intensification des efforts
actuels de noix dans le problème en voie
renens plan c'est le québécois est ce
qui est des critères spécifiques pour
qu'un immigrant en bénéficient les
personnes vont pouvoir trouver
l'information sur notre site internet
emploie sol québécois point ca
les critères majeurs qu'on regarde c'est
premièrement faut que la personne soit
autorisé à travailler au québec peu
importe le type de permis de travail que
ce soit une résidence permanente un
permis temporaire un pvt réfugiés
demandeurs d'asile
on les accepte on est sur la mesure de
recherche innovation du mts de services
québec
donc on est financé par le gouvernement
du québec faut aussi que le français
soit de niveau fonctionnel parce que les
employeurs en région travaille en
français la communauté francophone donc
une personne celle des pauvres vivent
d'isolement doit avoir un français
fonctionnel mais le français peut aussi
se perfectionner sur le milieu de
travail
ensuite on au niveau c'est des nouveaux
arrivants qu'on vise donc cinq ans et
moins au québec n'ayant pas eu de
première emplois dans le domaine de
formation de l'individu
des fois c'est aussi une occasion de
faire une réorientation de carrière
donc on a cette activité dans les trois
prochaines semaines
donc j'invite les gens à s'inscrire en
grand nombre voilà nathalie et impôts
est des projets à moyen terme toujours
vous avez vous êtes vous êtes très bien
là vous et dans les laurentides
c'est quoi la suite des choses les
projets sont dans le développement
d'affaires de mon entreprise
essentiellement qu'ils ont continué à
profiter de la vie de famille tous les
attraits de la région des laurentides
ben voilà un résultat qui suivent en
direct
nathalie rochefort dont il ya souvent
une catégorie d'immigrants qui sont les
ceux qui sont là depuis plus de cinq ans
qu'il semblait pris en charge mais vous
voulez récupérer vous n'avez pas de
problème avec ça nous en fait comme ça
tout à l'heure on n'est ni moins qu'une
question qui a besoin d'un service j'ai
besoin d'une ressource on va l'aider à
trouver parce que le choix de
l'immigration c'est d'abord et avant
tout une décision qui humaine qui
humainement beaucoup emprunt de
sentiments qui peuvent être mitigé un
peu comme un mariage avant de se marier
on pense que c'est tout bon ou tout
génial mais une fois que tu es marie tu
te rends compte que l'autre by ap tête
des défauts la baignoire et ai pas cool
donc ça amène un certain lot un certain
route défient donc on reste là la bonne
nouvelle qu'on a cette année que l'on
vient d'avoir lé pa très longtemps de
gamin maintenant une bonne maintenant
numéro de charité donc on peut accepter
des dons et émettre des reçus d'impôt
pour nous ça va faire une grande
différence parce que notre autonomie
face au gouvernement on itier parce que
c'est ce qui nous permet d'avoir un
accueil vraiment très générales de votre
problème on s'occupe de trouver une
solution surtout dans le réseau
immigrants québec dans les bottins parce
qu'on en parle et d'immigrants au québec
c'est pas seulement salon c'est aussi
délit violent de multiples ressources
il ya des choses son polo by lm soit pas
là mais bon elle aime c'est une
clientèle très particulière ces légumes
musulmans donc ils s'affichent pas
nécessairement partout donc mais bio
dans les réseaux on a toutes les rues
des réponses au juste posé la question
pour juste la partager et si
on l'a pas mon la pause sur twitter ou
sur facebook date it on trouve alors
justement ma dernière qui sont à tout le
monde c'est quoi le conseil que vous
donneriez pour nouveaux arrivants qui
nous écoutent en ce moment qu'ils ont
qu'ils soient des questions
d'intégration au québec
qu'est ce que vous diriez allez-y c'est
vraiment explorer les possibilités c'est
de découvrir d'être ouvert à laventure
parcourir des milliers de kilomètres
pour arriver au québec c'est déjà être
pionnier être innovateurs aller vers les
régions c'est une autre découverte
mais ces quelques centaines de
kilomètres parfois donc c'est vraiment
d'être ouvert à la vente sûrs de ce que
le québec peut offrir
quelqu'un d'autre un conseil et une
solution osez osez
moi je pense aux heroes et s'informer
parce que effectivement il ya plein
d'organismes permettant parce que je
pense que leurs plus grands enjeux
l'information texte si elle est
tellement dilué est tellement des ordres
donnés jeudi rien de trop d'information
puis d'être capable de pouvoir voir
quelqu'un qui puisse se référer à la
bonne place au bon moment et pas dans
des délais trop longs
c'est probablement la clé du succès donc
osé osé s'adresser aux organismes oser
explorer justement
informez vous on met en général et en
particulier donc effectivement bon salon
immigration points comme grand
quebec.com mai mais in fine et comme le
disait nathalie on a des guides on a des
plus de mille pages de ressources et de
référence donc après effectivement c'est
d'être capable de personnaliser son
parcours et de regarder qu'est ce qui
vous importe comme on disait à leur
ligne le disais c'est souvent un
parcours de vie sains il va y avoir un
couple de personnes qui travaillent
perte est une personne qui va lire aux
études ou des enfants
donc c'est tout un tas de préoccupations
différentes dont il faut tenir compte
dans un parcours on s'éloigne de chez
soi c'est pas simple donc c'est des gens
qui sont effectivement très courageux je
pense qu'ils prennent beaucoup sur eux
donc il faut que nous en tant que
société aussi on puisse les accompagner
pour ça il n'y a rien de mieux que
l'information avec le côté s'informer
explorer et puis oser et je pense qu'il
ya aussi une autre chose ces deux
valeurs québécoises que j'ai appris ici
et que j'apprécie énormément
c'est la générosité faire sa part dans
la communauté c'est une belle manière de
s'intégrer s'impliquer et puis aussi
rester humble oui et c'est une française
qui nous dit mais moi je voudrais aller
vers les autres
c'est nul c'est une initiative qui
humaine vous avez une question
ben oui vous pouvez regarder sur
internet pour trouver votre réponse mais
demandez peut-être votre vous avait
demandé au monsieur à la madame au
dépanneur ils vont heureux de vous aider
nathalie vous ne vienne parler de
générosité mais cette générosité là
c'est aussi d'informer ou de référé les
personnes va vers les bonnes ressources
ou vers d'autres bonnes personnes
oui à des organismes communautaires mais
dans les régions du québec est pas
toujours un organisme qui est leur
taille il ya des humains par exemple son
look sa grandeur du territoire québécois
voilà nathalie rochefort mathelier their
own amalric madame lagacé l'hymne de son
prénom est jeune attaché dalle merci
beaucoup d'être venu ici
vous qui nous écoutent et écouter merci
d'avoir été avec nous et puis on se dit
à une prochaine
ouart va coûter de main de maître merci
beaucoup d'amis